even occupy democrats they tweeted today
that in greece the government is fining
people 113 dollars per month because
they didn't take a product from a
private criminal multinational
organization they're also bragging that
in austria the government is finding
people stealing four thousand dollars
for them because they didn't take a
product from a big pharma agency this is
also going to be happening in quebec and
occupy democrats are asking retweet if
you want this to happen in the united
states which is absolutely ridiculous
they're on the side of literally forcing
you through the threat of stealing your
money or having guys show up with guns
and use violence against you if you
don't buy a product this is where
they're at they're absolutely fascists
totalitarian technocrats that have no
respect for human decency or your
personal property i have a i have a
tweet about this so uh here we have the
tweet they say greece announces that
will begin
finding the unvaccinated 113 dollars per
month austria announces that it'll begin
finding them for 4 000 finding them 4
000 a month and quebec announces it may
begin slapping them with a significant
fine retweet if you think america must
do it my response was no
we should just lock the unvaccinated
people in jail they can leave any time
as soon as they get the vaccine this way
we aren't forcing them to get vaccinated
and we keep people safe australia model
well i was concerned about that tweet
because they're gonna take your advice
so uh
i i often tweet
uh garbled nonsense and i have no
problem explaining why i do it
by tweeting the opposite in a slightly
slightly silly way
the average person of intelligence
understands my point
and
you can't take the tweet and assert
context to it
so
i luke posted a meme and i'm like i'm
looking at this meme and it's like you
know questioning you know vaccines and
things like that or it's the science and
the corporations around it
and i'm like if you post that they might
say you're posting medical
misinformation and ban you so i posted
it
very in a very silly way criticizing it
and pushing something that was absurd so
what are they going to do they going to
ban me for saying it was crazy yeah and
though most people understand my point
my response to this tweet was replying
to it with a gif of mussolini giving a
speech i saw that that was awesome like
that's also another way just mocking
these people because their ideas are
absurd and when we really break it down
what they're doing they're calling for
violent men with guns to come to people
and steal their money for not taking a
product that's essentially what it boils
down to and so let me just let's let me
just stress this point right now and i'm
going to say it again to make sure
everyone here sucks i really want the
bread tubers to hear this
if we are talking about the french
revolution and the right was as you
described i would say the aristocracy in
the left was the revolutionary
we sit before you today as humble civil
libertarians and big libertarians in a
certain sense saying the establishment
politician politicians are corrupt and
broken the massive multinational
corporations are criminal and they are
stripping the value and the rights of
the working class in this country
we believe that there needs to be
dramatic revolutionary change in this
country like ending the federal reserve
not depending on chinese slave labor and
not just ending the fed we would but
repeal it and then take control of the
finances with our congress restoring the
rights of the working class ending the
corrupt aristocracy and elitism in this
nation and letting good working-class
people have the fruits of their labor
from the labor they produce and many of
you
many of you sit there and say it is good
that nancy pelosi and joe biden corrupt
neo-neocon corporatists neolib
corporatists are mandating the american
people be forced to buy a product from a
massive multinational corporation
you are the right in your own argument
and we are the left we are to the left
of you and we're not even leftists
now if you want to talk about economic
scale when left means economic policy
collectivism or right is laissez-faire
that will have an argument for sure but
if you want to play that game of left
and right as tribes y'all on the on
bread tube are actually right wing for
defending the government and the
corporations as they do this
how does that happen isn't that weird
they must have changed aisles there at
some point they all got up and and
shuffled over i think that's why you got
to not get too hung up on the
definitions of the words rightist and
leftists because really yeah these you
can call yourself whatever you want but
if you're supporting multinational
corporate takeover that's authoritarian
as hell you know it's monarchist as hell
criminal entities with no liability for
their product that's forced and extorted
on the general public that's a whole new
level of craziness that has a criminal
past of of buying off regulators
politicians and doctors for pure profit
motive that they had to pay billions of
dollars in fines too pfizer is like in
the top 10 largest criminal uh cases in
the world yeah pfizer's like number five
or six or something for buying off
regulators scientists and politicians
you know in practice it's it's quite
often difficult to see the difference
between fascist regimes and communist
regimes
and one technically is government
ownership of the means of production the
other is government control of the means
of production but i've i've done a
pretty deep dive on this and if you look
at pol pot
the mass murder in cambodia
and you look at many of his policies not
just economics but civil liberties and
general disdain for life
it's fairly difficult to tell the
difference between him and adolf hitler
and yet we're taught that these guys are
in opposite ends of the the political
spectrum no they're both murderous
authoritarians and and my my mine's
different than you i put the bad guys on
the bottom
i i get the the metaphor of putting us
on the bottom but uh as you move up my
political scale you get to
all the things that are voluntary
cooperation and choice
and and informed consent and all these
crazy radical ideas that that neither
political establishment will tolerate
today and to me it goes back to your
your manifesto that you laid out there
that's that's where we can find
reasonable people and it almost feels
like it's in the middle even though it's
outside of the current structure
altogether it's the people that spin
around all through it and are willing to
engage and understand all of it that are
seem like they're in the middle it's
happening so fast that it just looks
like it's it's right there yeah those
are the people i'm looking for
well i think we found them tonight
in the comments
or they're all saying we're foolish
no i think um
the people who watch tend to be fairly
moderate
you know nobody's an extremist in in you
know
in any sense maybe a few people pop in
here and there we get some leftists who
just hate us and they're very
authoritarian you know tanky types but
for the most part you know the people i
meet on the street regular people and
they're just you know the response i
usually get from people is they're like
i don't know man i just want to be able
to to live to feed my family to get by i
don't want to hurt anybody i don't want
to i don't want to cause problems i just
want things to get better and i want
people to chill out yeah that's a lot of
it
you got a lot of people who are like we
want to go crazy we want to go to war we
want dramatic revolutionary change by
any means necessary and you know the one
thing i find fascinating because i've
talked to a lot of antibiotic people
about this
i said isn't the use of violence against
someone inherently authoritarian
and they just they never have a real
answer for it you might get these
sophists who are like actually the use
of violence isn't because and i'm like
what about beating someone until they
agree with you is not authoritarian
because is it authoritarianism strict
adherence to the authority or or
governance or politics
based upon adherence to the authority
and the use of violence is authoritarian
to force them to do it whereas
libertarian would be like sitting down
over a cup of coffee and having a
discussion and an argument and trying to
convince them persuasion right well
defense of violence i guess could be a
libertarian thing
in uh you know we have this thing called
the non-aggression principle that if you
you can't mess with somebody else but if
they mess with you they threaten your
your life or your property you have a
right to defend yourself
um but but back to your point i think
this is super important
antifa's model is explicitly violent
they're quite proud of it and and they
think that violent change is the only
way to sort of transform society break
the system
and you know all of these all of these
communist dictators tried this stuff and
they
didn't give one damn about human life
our strategy has to be the difference
different fundamentally different ours
has to be non-violent because violence
is the ultimate violation of of
liberties and
and people's humanity so
i think there's power
in non-violence and i'm a student i'm a
student of martin luther king
and gandhi and i've studied these
non-violent movements the solidarity
movement
who would have thought
that a bunch of guys could gather
and beat
this all-powerful soviet regime with
non-violence they did it
so i think our tactics have to be
different
and which is why i was so critical about
january 6
um aping the other guys
is a losing strategy you're saying with
the soviet is the peace what was the
party name you said that defied the
soviets solidarity movement
it was a movement of union workers and
people coming together throughout the
factories that they were mandated to
work at saying no we're going to protest
we're not going to work for the soviet
empire we're going to strike and because
of those strikes and that kind of
collective collective bargaining power
it was one of the reasons out of many
why the soviet empire kind of crumbled
and for those which my family was a part
of in uh dinosaur poland and a little a
little bit of trivia for you guys for
those that are fans of the game
civilization in the video game
civilization 2 which is a very early
version of it
you're you're you're creating a country
when you have civil unrest it actually
shows an image from the solidarity
movement they're holding the big sign
and protesting and that's the symbol
used in the game of unrest in your city
cool stuff huh
a lot of history there um and it shows
you that protests throughout history
sometimes do work now there's a lot of
peasants that say protests never work
but i think it's worth a try and i
definitely agree with you we should we
should always strive to be non-violent
we should also have the ability to
defend ourselves if if the need comes
but prioritize that non-violence over
anything else because the state has
mastered the tool of
of of anger of hatred and of violence in
such a way that there's no using it in
any way that it doesn't benefit them
directly thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time